[Applause]
all right so we've talked to molly about
her
shows that are just crushing it i can
think of something else that might bring
that same fervor
and it's a little movie called scream
so
there is a new
scream coming out and
what i can gather
um and talking to courtney
and you know a few of the alumni
um and a few of the new cast members is
that they're taking an interesting and
different approach can you tell me
anything
without getting arrested in movie jail i
can tell you that i love playing the
role of dewey it's such an iconic role
thank you
um
that matt and tyler were inspired by
west to become filmmakers they're the
two directors that are part of a group
called radio silence that did the film
but they were inspired by wes so they
really wanted to make a tribute like a
real something that he'd be proud of
and uh there's an incredible cast i mean
i think people are really going to be
excited about it i think i can't say
[Music]
you know i don't know you guys are and
you guys are angelino's do you all know
about the hollywood forever cemetery
screenings yeah okay these things are
legendary i mean i'm talking five seven
thousand people show up on the night to
go to uh a cemetery and watch movies and
they did a slumber party just a few
weeks ago um i know because um also
billy eilish texted me and showed me
that she dressed up as casey becker
and i've recently made friends with her
i'm freaking out
and um it's like you have literally
legends like billy eilish showing up for
this this movie has stood the test of
time it's capturing the hearts of you
know our generation new generations
and a film like that deserves not just a
sequel but a reinvention and a respect
for the classic
so
i'm i'm really excited about that and
it'll be great for you and i
to see that legacy alive and well
[Music]